طاهر ومحمد شريكان في مطعم تونسي يقع في
احد الاحياء الباريسيه مع بدايه شهر رمضان
لاحظ انخفاضا نسبه اقبال الزبائن علما ان
تجارتهما كانت تزدهر في هذه الفتره من
السنه لكن ازمه التضخم حاله دون ذلك
ما يخلصش اكثر من اللي موجود في جيبه بل
ناس تخلص عادي
وتبارك الله اخي ربي موجود كانوا ارخص مع
حلول شهير رمضان حاله من الركود تسود
الاسواق العربيه في فرنسا فمظاهر الاحتفال
بالشهر الفضيل هذا العام اصبحت اقل حضورا
من ذي قبل نتيجه ازمه التضخم التي ضرت
البلاد على القدره الشرائيه للمستهلكين
غلاء الاسعار هذا العام جعل تكلفه المائده
الرمضانيه اكبر بكثير مما كانت عليه لذا
اعتمدت العائلات المسلمه سياسه التوفير
لتجنب الاستهلاك غير الضروري منكسروش منها
اكثر من اللازم على خاطر غاليه احنا نعيشه
هنا في الخارج عنا
برشا حاجات نخلصوا فيها منجموش
نتعدوا اكثر من لازم ناخذه نختاروا
الحاجات ضروريه
نستحقها كل يوم
وناكلوها معناها
على الحاجات
منطيشوش وتشير الارقام الاخيره الى ان
معدل التضخم في فرنسا تجاوز عتبه السته في
المئه فيما قفزت اسعار المواد الغذائيه
بنسبه
14.8
زين عدي العربيه باريس